what I hope to do in this video is prove
that if a function is differentiable at
some point see that it's also going to
be continuous at that point C but before
we do the proof let's just remind
ourselves what differentiability means
and what continuity means
so first differentiability differentia
differentiability so let's think about
that first it's always helpful to draw
ourselves a function so that's our
y-axis this is our this is our x-axis
and let's just draw some function here
so let's say my function looks like this
and we care about the point x equals C
which is right over here so that's the
point x equals C and then this value of
course is going to be F of C F of C and
one way that we can find the derivative
at X equal C or the slope of the tangent
line at x equals C is we could start
with some other point say some arbitrary
X out here so let's say this is some
arbitrary X out here so then this point
right over there this value this Y value
would be f of X would be f of X this
graph of course is a graph of y equals f
of X and we can think about finding the
slope of this line this secant line
between these two points but then we can
find the limit as X approaches C and as
X approaches C this secant the slope of
the secant line is going to approach the
slope of the tangent line is going to be
the derivative and so we could take the
limit the limit as X approaches C as X
approaches C of the slope of this secant
line so what's the slope what's going to
be change in Y over change in X the
change in Y is f of X minus f of C
that's our change in Y right over here
this is all a review this is just a one
definition of the derivative or one way
to think about the derivative so it's
going to be f of X minus f of C that's
our change in Y
over our change in x over our change in
X which is X minus C it is X minus X
minus C so if this limit exists then
we're able to find the slope of the
tangent line at this point and we call
that slope of the tangent line we call
that the derivative at x equals C we say
that this is going to be equal to F
prime F prime of C all of this is review
so if we're saying one way one way to
think about it if we're saying that the
function f is differentiable at x equals
C we're really just saying that this
limit right over here actually exists
and if this limit actually exists we
just call that value F prime of C so
that's just a review of
differentiability now let's give
ourselves a review of continuity con to
new ax t so the definition for
continuity is if the limit as X
approaches C of f of X is equal to f of
C now this might seem a little bit you
know
well it might it might pop out to you as
being intuitive or it might seem a
little well where did this come from
well let's visualize it and then
hopefully it'll make some intuitive
sense so if you have a function so let's
actually look at some cases where you're
not continuous and that actually might
make it a little bit more clear so if
you had a point discontinuity at x
equals C so this is x equals C so if you
had a point discontinuity so let me draw
it like this actually so you have a gap
here and x equals when x equals C F of C
is actually way up here so this is f of
C and then the function continues like
this the limit as X approaches C of f of
X is going to be this value which is
clearly different than f of C this value
right over here if you take the limit if
you take the limit as X approaches C of
f of X you're approaching this value
this right over here is the limit as X
approaches C
of f of X which is different than f of C
so it makes so this this definition of
continuity seems to be good at least for
this case because this is not a discount
this is this is not a continuous
function you have a point discontinuity
so for at least in this case are this
this definition of continuity would
properly identify this as not a
continuous function now you could also
think about a jump discontinuity you
could also think about a jump
discontinuity so let's look at this and
all this is hopefully a little bit of
review so jump discontinuity at C at x
equals C might look like this might look
might look like this so this is at x
equals C so this is x equals C right
over here this would be F of C but if
you try to find evaluate the limit as X
approaches C of f of X you get a
different value as as you approach C
from the negative side you would
approach this value and as you approach
C from the positive side you would
approach f of C and so the limit
wouldn't exist so this limit right over
here wouldn't exist in the case of a
jump of this type of a jump
discontinuity so once again this
definition would properly say that this
is not this this one right over here is
not continuous this limit actually would
not even exist and then you could even
look at a you could look at a function
that is truly continuous if you look at
a function that is truly continuous so
something like this something like this
that is x equals C well this is f of C
this is f of C and if you were to take
the limit as X approaches C as X
approaches C from either side of f of X
you're going to approach f of C so here
you have the limit as X approaches C of
f of X indeed is equal to f of C so it's
what you would expect for a continuous
function so now that we've done that
review of differentiability and
continuity let's prove that
differentiability actually implies
continuity and I think it's important to
kind of do this review just so that you
can really visualize things so
differentiability implies this
this this limit right over here exists
so let's start with a slightly different
limit let's limit let me draw a line
here actually let me draw a line too
just so we're doing something different
so let's take let us take the limit as X
approaches C of f of X of f of X minus F
of C of f of X minus f of C well can we
rewrite this well we could rewrite this
as the limit as X approaches C and we
can essentially take this expression and
multiply and divide it by X minus C so
let's multiply it times X minus C X
minus C and divide it time divided by X
minus C so we have f of X minus f of C
all of that over X minus C so all I did
is I multiplied and I divided by X minus
C well what's this limit going to be
equal to this is going to be equal to
it's going to be the limit and I'm just
applying the property of limit property
this I'm gonna brought up by a property
of limits here so the limit of the
product is equal to the same thing as a
product of the limits so the limit as X
approaches C of X minus C times the
limit let me write it this way times the
limit as X approaches C of f of X minus
f of C all of that over X minus C now
what is what is this thing right over
here well if we assume that F is
differentiable at C at C and we're going
to do that actually I should have
started off there let's assume let's
assume because we wanted to start your
show the differentiability improves
continuity if we assume F differentiable
differentiable at C well then this right
over here is just the is just going to
be F prime of C this right over here we
just saw it right over here that's this
exact same thing this is F prime F prime
of C and what is this thing right over
here the limit as X approaches C of X
minus C
well that's just going to be zero as X
approaches C that's going to become C
minus C is just going to be zero
so what's zero times F prime of C well F
prime of C is just going to be some
value so zero times anything is just
going to be zero so do I did all that
work to get a zero now why is this
interesting well we just said we just
assumed that if f is differentiable at C
and we evaluate this limit we get zero
so if we assume F is differentiable at C
we can write we can write the limit I'm
just rewriting it the limit as X
approaches C of f of X minus f of C and
I could even put parentheses around it
like that right which I already did up
here is equal to zero well this is the
same thing I could use limit properties
again this is the same thing as saying
I'll do it over here but actually let me
do it down here the limit as X
approaches C of f of X minus the limit
as X approaches C of f of C of f of C is
equal to 0 the different the limit of
the difference is the same thing as the
difference of the limits well what's
this thing over here going to be well F
of C is just a number it's not a
function of X anymore it's just F of C
is going to evaluate to something so
this is just going to be f of C this is
just going to be F of C so the limit of
f of X as X approaches C minus f of C is
equal to 0 we'll just add F of C to both
sides and what you get will you get the
limit as X approaches C of f of X is
equal to f of C and this is the
definition of continuity the limit the
limit of my function is X approaches C
is equal to the function is equal to the
value of the function at C at C this is
this means that our function is
continuous continuous at C so just a
reminder we started assuming f
differentiable at C we use that fact to
evaluate this limit right over here
which we got to be equal
to zero and if that limit is equal to
zero then it just follows just doing a
little bit of algebra and using
properties of limits that the limit as X
approaches C of f of X is equal to f of
C and that's our definition of being
continuous continuous at the point C so
hopefully that satisfies you if we know
that the derivative exists at a point if
it's differentiable at a point C that
means it's also continuous at that point
C the function is also continuous at
that point